منذ نحو شهر عندما بدات اخر فصول ازمات
شيرين مع حسام اخر ما كان يتوقعه جمهور
شيرين ان يصلهم اشعار الى هواتفهم يعلن
عوده النجمه الى طليقها حسام بعد نحو عام
تقريبا من الاعلان الانفصال عام تخلله
الكثير جدا من الازمات اهمها ربما ايداع
شيرين مصحه للعلاج من الادمان شيرين تخرج
وتعلن ببساطه في مكالمه هاتفيه عدت لحسام
حبيب اشكرك جمهوري واعدكم اللي اخذ لكم
ابدا لكننا جمهوره شيرين يشعر بالظهور
والدعم الذي استمر طوال الاسابيع الماضيه
تحول الى غضب وطالب البعض حتى بمقاطعه
الفنانه ومع ان اختيار الانسان لشركه امره
الشخصيه لكن محبي شيرين يقولون كما يقول
المثل الشعبي العتب على قدر المحبه سنذهب
الى القاهره حيث استطعنا راي الشارع هناك
مع زميلتنا
اعوذ بكلمات الله التامات من شر ما خلق
فهذا يعني امان للبيوت ونسال الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان يجمع بينكما في الخير والسعاده
انه قريب ذلك مولاه والقادر عليه
بين شيرين عبد الوهاب وحسام حبيب في صدمه
كبيره من نهايته زواج ثم طلاق والكثير من
التصريحات المثيره للجدل واخيرا العوده
مره اخرى كازواج والسؤال هنا ما راي
الشارع المصري في احداث هذا المسلسل مساء
الخير مساء النور ازيك
[موسيقى]
موضوع انها دخلت مصحه نفسيه
فطبعا ده في حد ذاته تشهير لشخصيتها نفسها
فالمفروض ان اي حد مكانه هيقول لك لا
كفايه كده المثل بيقول لك الحب اعمى
ولو كان حتى قرد وهي حبته وحب السعوديه
حاسه ربنا في البني ادم
الحب ده
ده مرض لو هما فعلا صح طبعا لا قرار غلط
طبعا لان هي كده اتظلمت نفسها بعد الاهانه
والكلام اللي اتقال عليها ده كله
والمخدرات والكلام ده كله هي ترجع ثاني
بعد كده بقى لما هو يعمل فيها اكثر من كده
تبقى تستاهل اللي هي حلقه شعرها ليه ليه
عملت ده كله في نفسها طالما هي ترجع له في
النهايه ده حبها الجنون ده حب جنون ده حب
جنون ليه يعني طبيعي لا لا ده الحب اللي
يفهم الحب صح هي بتحبه بجد فعشان بتحب بجد
عشان هي مش متصوره نفسها مع احد ثاني غير
حسام حبيبي
[موسيقى]
نستمع مجددا الى ما قالته شيرين في برنامج
الزميل عمرو اديب
انت عندك خبر سعيد عايزه تقولي لي الناس
وانا حابب ان الخبر ده يتقال عندنا هنا في
البرنامج عشان نفرح معاك كل الناس ايه
الخبر السعيد اللي عندك النهارده
[موسيقى]
بمشيئه رب العالمين كتب كتابي على السيد
حسام
الف مبروك الله يبارك فيك الله يبارك فيك
انت يا اللي عامل مش عارف ههه
[موسيقى]
باتعلم منك وعايزه اقول للناس ادعوا لي
عشان انا ما اقدرش اعيش من غير دعواتكم
ليا ورضاكم
كتاب امتى
[موسيقى]
بحضور اقرب الناس المقربين جدا لينا
انا كل من القاهره ينظم مصطفى محمود سيد
مصطفى اهلا بك شكرا تواجدك معنا كيف تم
الاستعانه بك اولا لاخراج المطربه شيرين
من المستشفى من طلب من كذلك تحديدا
استاذ هو الموضوع
من حسام حبيب اللي هو طريق الفنانه
توجهت للمستشفى في اليوم دوت لان كان في
محاولات قبليها في النيابه وفي المستشفى
نفسها من الاستاذ ياسر الدوس اللي هو
محامي الفنانه
والمحاولاتنا مع الاداره والمستشفى وكان
الناس تعاونوا معنا وقالوا انه ما فيش
مشكله انها تخرج
الاستاذ ياسر
مصطفى لم يكن هناك ان المستشفى لم تكن
ترفض خروج شيرين منها لانه كان في منشدات
في السابق
لا طبعا
محضر موجود في النيابه وكان في همم
طلب ما قدموا للاستاذ ياسر للمجلس
الاقليمي الصحه عشان خاطر تعنته المستشفى
في عدم خروج الفنانه لان طبعا كان في
اخطاء كثير في دخولها وعدم خروجها وبقاء
في المستشفى المده دي كلها يعني طيب استاذ
مصطفى ما الذي دفع عقلي قبول هذه الخطوه
خصوصا انه الكل يعرف انه لشرين عندها
محامي هو الاستاذ ياسر انطوش
هو سعادتك طبعا زي ما قلت حكم كان في
محاوله سابقه في نفس اليوم يعني
وطبعا بقت بالفشل
فلما انا طبعا درست الكلام اللي هم
قالهولي والمده اللي هي كانت موجوده فيها
الفنانه
فطبعا حضرتك احنا عندنا قانون اللي هو 71
لسنه 2009 ده اللي بينظم دخول المريض
المستشفى سواء ارادي او او الزلزام فطبعا
المده ما بتقعدش الكلام ده كله مش موجود
في القانون لان لها مده فتره زمنيه
وبيتبلغ المجلس الاقليمي للسياحه النفسيه
عشان خاطر بقاءها او عدم بقائها في
المستشفى فانا كنت شايف من دراسه الموقف
كله ان في مخالفه واضحه من المستشفى وتعنت
ليه طبعا عشان كده انا دخلته والحمد لله
ربنا يوفقني وهمم وخرجناها والمفروض ان
احنا كنا هنروح ناخذها ثاني يوم بس همم
طبعا الزملاء الاستاذ ياسر الاستاذ حسام
حبيب راح اخذوها قبل ميعادنا مثلا بساعتين
ثلاثه
طيب في هذه الحاله استاذ مصطفى
على حقك الادبي والماده من الطرف الاخر
بعد كل ما حصل بعد خبر رجوع شيرين الى
حسام حبيب
والله
ربنا ما يجيبش حاجه وحشه لايمن اقدم وهي
فنانه طبعا تستاهل مننا ان احنا ندعي لها
ان انا ربنا
يعينها وربنا يوفقها على قرار الصح يعني
بس طبعا انا كنت طلعت قبل كده في مداخله
مع
الاستاذ الاعلامي الكبير تامر امين
الحياه الادب بتاعي انا اخذته بنشر
الفيديو طبعا استاذ تامر يعني اتكلم في
الحته دي والناس
الداخليه او حق المادي
وطبعا بعد الرجوع ده طبعا اكيد في تفكير
ثاني بالذات ان هم دلوقت متجاهلين وهمم
وما فيش احد طبعا حاول التواصل ليا رغم
ظهور الاعلامي فطبعا انا اعتقد
الايام الجايه اجراءات القرانيه طبعا
للحصول الادبي والمادي طب حسب المعلومات
التي نشرت مؤخرا عن ازمه شيرين تم اجبارها
على دخول المستشفى من الناحيه القانونيه
هل يجوز ذلك
بينظم دخول قانون الصحه النفسيه 71 لسنه
91 2009
في دخول ايرادي ودخول الزامي دخول
الالزامه طبعا بيبقى خاضع لان اللي بيعمل
الاجراء ده طبيب نفسي بناء على ظهور في
الحاله النفسيه للمريض لو في تهديد له
الصحه العامه وصحه وصحه الاخرين او ان
تدهور في حاله الصحيه طبعا الكلام ده
وبيرفع
المنشئه بترفع تقرير في خلال 24 ساعه من
دخول المريض للمجلس الاقليمي للسياحه
النفسيه للبث في في استمرار وجودها او عدم
استدعاء وجودها في المستشفى التلقي العلاج
طبعا الكلام ده في حالات الفنانه هنطبقه
عليها هو طبعا ما ما ما ما تعملش
الاجراءات دي والاجراءات كلها يعتبر يعني
همم فيها بطلان
وطبعا الاستاذ ياسر بقى هو اللي متكفل
الموضوع ده
مع الاستاذ تامر امين وبيقول لي حته
الخروج اللي هو ان هي خرجت مع الاستاذ قلت
له والله انا اشك في الكلام ده لان اللي
انا شفته والاستعانه بي طبعا ان هو
الاستاذ حسام حبيب واستاذ حسام الشيخ كان
هو اللي موجود في ال- اا يعني قبل تبعا
انت واكذب همم بايام وموجود في النيابه في
نفس اليوم عشان همم يقول بقى قال عشان
يخرجها وهو اكثر واحد كان صاحب المصلحه
وهمم اكيد هم كانوا على تواصل بكده وهو
طبعا يعني اكيد كان منتظرها عشان الخطوه
اللي هم عملوها دي يعني كل الموضوع ده كان
مرتب وهمم واضح وكان موجود بس طبعا هو ما
كانش ظاهر على الساحه عشان كان السوشيال
ميديا والاعلام كان عامل دقه في الموضوع
ده شكرا